our Leroy well welcome to camp et thank
you who do you think I think this is
really amazing this glamorous life yeah
sweet chairs with the with the juice
boxes exactly
cheers to convince your from Spain right
yes yes did you ever like camper as a
kid or anything I haven't done much much
caffeine actually yeah neither am i go
with my dad's and fishing and that's
about oh nice
do you have a favorite summer memory
then like when you think of summer
what's the first memory that comes to
mind
pull friends really see we didn't have a
pool growing up I was like running
through the sprinklers in my arm yeah
well I didn't have a pool either wait
there was like the community pool where
like everybody would go like massive
pool so that was I love it so this is my
first time I've it calm I've it'd con I
think this is yours as well yes first
time so what do you think so far it's
crazy it's amazing it's kind of awesome
that's very cool I mean it's great to
see you know all the fans and all the
you know creators as well walking around
it's really cool how'd you get your
start like what like when did you start
like posting videos on YouTube 2007 I
did yeah a long time ago I mean were you
just like down to just like play played
something and just get it up there and
upload yeah it was um I remember seeing
just a few people doing covers because
back in the days you know it wasn't a
huge thing right right and I thought it
was the coolest thing I'm like oh man
this person is plain
somebody else a song and I'm watching it
as like people are commenting and
they're from all over the world loving
it yeah yeah so I was like oh I want to
you know I want to know what other
people think about my singing and that
was the whole you know that's how I
started I'm right and here you are now
it can't be so you are actually about to
go on tour I am that's awesome talk to
me about the tour I am opening for Boyce
Avenue in September and I'm super super
excited because they're an incredible
band yeah
what are your essentials like what do
you bring with you on tour so you could
I mean that's a lot of traveling it is
you want to bring a pillow yes a good
pillow for the for the long rides
probably protein bars because a lot of
times you can eat well thanks for
hanging out man yeah so much fun